welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar advances
in three-dimensional cell culture in
drug research and discovery presented by
dr. Richard Eglin vice president and
general manager of Corning Life Sciences
my name is dr. Susie Bell des and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to simply click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and type your questions
into the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just simply click on the
ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming our presenter today
dr. Richard Eglin I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thank you thank you Susie um it's a
pleasure to talk to everyone today about
this exciting field of 3d cell culture
and as the title indicates I'd like to
talk about how it's got applications
both for drug discovery research as well
as and developing novel disease models
and we'll talk a bit about that as well
um the areas I plan to cover is really
to give everyone a broad overview of
this area of cell culture and how it is
applied to studying cells in three
dimensions we'll refer to this as 3d
cell culture I'll then give an overview
of the various techniques
some tools used in 3d culture and then
spend the majority of the talk
subsequently talking about all of the
various applications of 3d culture as
well so the point being if you go back
and look at the history of cell culture
and you can stretch your mind back way
back to a couple of centuries ago it was
recognized that embryonic cells from
animals such as chickens could be kept
alive several days outside of the body
in a salt solution and that then led to
various methods by which one could study
tissues outside of the body it led in
the early nineteen hundreds to
development of synthetic media's that
were obviously man-made but optimized to
keep different sorts of cells around and
then this also then led in the 50s to
the development of microtiter plates
which have become the workhorse in many
labs for both drug research and drug
discovery because pellet penicillin was
developed in the 20s that enabled the
Foundation's to be made for having
effective cell culture methods free of
contamination from environmental
bacteria and then the first immortalized
cell lines were developed the famous one
being the HeLa cells from Henrietta
Lacks that was the first one the first
immortalized cell lines that were
developed for widespread drug research
various improvements came along in the
50s including the ability to cope glass
surfaces and indeed other surfaces with
proteins such as collagen that improves
cell attachment and growth and then
plastic came in as workhorses in terms
of growing cells flasks this is 96 well
plates as well Anchorage dependent cells
were being developed at that time such
that you can grow them on other sorts of
surfaces including micro carriers very
very small particles which increases the
surface area for growth and then on the
cell culture side those are develop
of Feustel hybrids different sorts of
cell lines fused together and the
creation of hybridoma lines which we use
initially for the production of various
antibodies so all of that activity led
up to the late seventies whereby the
routine culture of cell cultures
normalized where the routine growth from
immortalized cell lines was widely
established and the development of
synthetic media surfaces but which you
can optimize your skill conditions going
from the 80s onwards it became apparent
that you could maybe improve this from
growing cells on a flat surface in a
two-dimensional system to starting to
look at cells as to how they appear in
three dimensions
in other words mimicking the situation
of the cells in vivo and artificial 3d
matrices were developed in the 80s and
then a milestone was reached in 1987 by
the development of Maitre gel which is
now available through corning life
sciences and that was first used to grow
Mouse sarcoma cell lines in the 80s
human army embryonic cell lines are
first isolated in the 90s implanted
organs were first grown from lab
lab-grown sources and then there was a
development of a range of novel surfaces
including the development of ultra low
attachment surfaces on a whole variety
of vessels and these enable different
cell lines to be grown once it adhered
there could be expanded and that could
be grown in very large vessels indeed
bio printing started to enter the field
in the 2000s there where you can now
print synthetic tissues as well as just
letting them grow and that started to
open up the ability to have
architectural II organized spatially
located cells and that has led in turn
to the development of organoids
including for example in 2008 the 3d
culture of brain tissues where you're
now starting to recapitulate not just
cells grown in 3d but
grown in the right location in the right
proximity to other cells and then mr.
field has developed such that by latest
2009 for example complex structures such
as blood vessels were beginning to be
bio printed as well so I put this in
because I thought the audience might be
interested in putting 3d cell culture in
sharp perspective that it represents the
end of a long line of development of
technologies by which you can take cells
from the body grow them outside of the
body look at them as disease models look
at them as mechanisms to interrogate for
drug action and 3d culture represents
the culmination of many of these years
of activity in fact if you look at this
slide here and there are basically three
types of cell lines used in cell culture
the first one of course is and I refer
to this with the HeLa cells is
immortalized cells these are originally
taken in general from animals and humans
they are optimized to grow on plastic
surfaces and they are indeed used widely
throughout R&D both in the academic
setting as well as in the drug discovery
setting they are easy to grow they grow
in a very reproducible fashion in very
large amounts and for that reason they
have become the workhorses for many R&D
labs the other major cell line type are
primary cells which are taken directly
from the human body that often grown on
biological surfaces and they are
increasing in terms of their use in
terms of drug discovery major reason of
course is that they can be taken
directly from the patient and as a
result of that they have the ability to
carry many of the disease
characteristics on board such that you
can start to look at drug action there
and then finally stem cells have started
to become more and more routinely use
the advantage of stem cells is that you
can isolate them from several human
tissues you can grow them on biological
surfaces
and they don't simply provide optimal
disease models but they can themselves
be used as therapeutics the point being
here is that if you look at the
continuum from left to right the
relevance of these cells goes from low
to high in that immortalized cells by
virtue of being immortalized tend to
have a low relevance in terms of biology
but stem cells of course have a very
high relevance contrast that with the
difficulty of using them immortalized
cells are easy to use easy to grow easy
to isolate but as you go through primary
cells and indeed stem cells they become
more difficult to work with more
difficult to isolate and as a result
more difficult to use now let's focus
now on 3-dimensional cell culture
because the goal here and the theme I'm
developing is that and one is wanting to
look at cell culture techniques and
cells themselves where they have
improved biological relevance that's
important in disease modeling it's very
important in terms of looking at the
pharmacological action of drugs and
growing cells in 3d culture enables one
to take a step in that direction the
slide here shows in fact what happens to
cells and the figure on the Left they're
the 2d cell culture is a cell grown on a
plastic plate it does some sort of
surface treatment there but you can see
that in contrast to the cells grown on
the right where have they have
spontaneously come together to form an
aggregate a three-dimensional structure
known as a steroid and two things to
know one of which is the appearance of
the cells looks very very different but
of course the figure on the right starts
to mimic how cells interact in the body
and in fact if the structure on the
right was a model of a tumor
for example then these storage
structures mimic very well many of the
sellers of associations one sees in
cancer there as well parenthetically
it's not just the appearance of the cell
that is different it's also their
genetics it's also their phenotype and
it's often the expression of cell
surface proteins that differs from when
you look at them in two dimensions as to
when you look at them in three
dimensions now this line here shows in
fact the spectrum going from 2d
Illustrated on the previous slide right
the way up through to increasing levels
of complexity so taking the going from
left to right here you can see that 2d
culture as I alluded to on the previous
slide can now be taking those cells
growing them in terms of a spheroid
where they form such very cool
aggregates there if you leave them to
differentiate or you add various growth
factors or differentiating factors or
specialized media the cells can
differentiate into organoids where you
tend to get aggregation of more than one
cell type and you start to set up the
various primitive org organ type
structures because these can also then
continue to develop into tissue systems
in some cases all the way through to
simple organs Illustrated here is the
skin for example right the way up to on
the far right they're complex organ
structures illustrated here well we've
got an assembly of cells forming a liver
system and of course that itself is very
important because now one can start to
look at the effects of compounds on the
liver outside of the body and I'm going
to come back to that at the end of this
talk because that's an illustration of
the power of 3d cell culture and similar
to the previous slide
um 2d to complex organ systems by way of
3d culture of course goes from low
relevance to high biological relevance
but the complexity increases as well as
you'll expect so low complexity into the
high complexity in organoids and complex
organ systems
taking a steroid here and this
biochemical illustration shown on the
right of the slide is meant to indicate
some of the intricate micro environment
one can now start to detect when cells
come together in assemblies this is a
steroid again and you can see here with
the various sections study with the
whole range of different technologies
how the cells can be studied in terms of
a 3d structure and by the way throughout
the talk where I've used illustrations
from the literature the primary
literature reference is also indicated
on the slide here and subsequent slides
as you can see taking the image on the
right you can see with with a steroid
for example it's well known that has
cells assembly into these aggregates the
oxygen gradient decreases and from the
exterior to the interior and that's
shown there on the upper right of the
diagram there and as a result of that
you get correspondingly subsequent
biochemical changes the distribution of
ATP reflective and metabolism of the
cells varies so on the outside is high
on the interior it's low and that is
also reflected in the distribution of
glucose there you can see it's high on
the outside it's low on the interior as
well correspondingly since low oxygen
conditions lead to lactic acid
accumulation you can see in the sense of
the steroid that took acid accumulation
is high it's lower on the outside and
indeed all of these effects
biochemically collectively relate to in
some cases differences in
differentiation and proliferation of the
cells and in the interior of the steroid
you can in fact at the time get frank
necrosis and that's illustrated not just
by the histopathology but right down at
the DNA level where you start to see DNA
strand breaks which is themselves a
reflection of necrosis or cell death
including apoptosis now this is what one
can see in a steroid and of course this
is exactly what one sees in a tumor
and as a result of this in in this case
if you had the appropriate cell you have
a very good model in fact in a 3d cell
culture system of what the tumour would
look like in the body when one wants to
study steroids you can now do this
routinely and in this case a calling is
one of many companies making microtiter
plates although Corning is only company
that can do this in an ultra high
throughput screening system using a 1536
well steroids will go very well in
microtiter plates and you can see that
the if they're in the ninety six or a
three for all the 1536 well format that
can use form of drug discovery and drug
development and increasingly steroids
are used in high-throughput screening
campaigns but they are also increasingly
used as toxicology models whereby you
can get good prediction of the effect of
compounds in terms of their potential
drug toxicity or drug metabolism not to
be covered today is the applications of
steroids and 3d culture in other areas
and this field is moving into bio
production particularly in the
production of vaccines as well as
biologics and finally when these and
time of stem cells growing them in 3d
particularly generations of embryo in
bodies they can be used for not just an
era P but also areas of tissue
engineering today I want to focus on the
application of 3d culture spheroid
culture in the use of drug discovery in
drug development um be a continuation
are the steroid as I mentioned on in one
of the illustrations previously is is
our 3d culture is now moving into tissue
organoids and these are providing near
physiological models by which one can
start to look at the development of
human cells human organs as well as the
impact and development of human disease
and in fact you can consider that an
organ ID is a variety of tissue culture
techniques that can provide a system
of cells that is self-organizing self
differentiating and self renewing giving
you a 3d cell culture system now some
examples of this are shown coming up
here for example if one takes a
pancreatic org organoid and these
Assemblies of pancreatic cells which
have differentiated are grown in a
Maitre Dell then you can see with these
mouth cells here and the goal of this
experiment was to to study beta cells in
the pancreas that can produce insulin
and how can you modulate these cells and
optimize them as memes to produce
insulin and therefore study some of the
fundamental disease processes involved
in diabetes other cell lines that have
been developed from stem cells to make
complex or organoids include this
illustration here with lung organoids
and here the group was using cells to
mimic in the lung and they could produce
definitive mezzo and pulmonary ended
IRMS and eventually they could produce
branching Airways and alveoli and in
fact they use this as a disease model by
which they could look at infections for
example of SimCity or virus so growing
the cells into a lung organoid also
enabled them to start to develop a
disease model and in fact start to look
at how viral infection of lung tissue
proceeds and then a final example of
this of 3d culture when looking at
organoid this is a gastric organ owed
here as well in this case this is also
groaning Maitre D' Altis as it is in the
previous slide here human iPS see cells
have been grown into an endoderm tissue
the steroids are then directed using
various growth factors to form tissues
that had gastric glands pit like
glandular domains and from this system
the researchers could identify novel
signaling domains in always looking at
the fundamental organization and the
biochem
history of the cells and they could also
look at infection of things like h
pylori as well which is a fundamental
cause of human ulceration the slide here
shows I'm taking other intestinal
organized looking about in 96 well
that's the procedure we've developed
here at cording to develop intestinal
organized it's done in a steroid plate
in a Maitre dell system and you can see
that in the illustrations at the bottom
there indicate that you can start to see
the correct cellular organization with
the correct staining allowing on you to
see a variety of different cell types
there so given these examples and given
that long history i talked about and
given the acceleration in terms of
technologies you could reasonably ask
the question if cell culture has been
around for over a century why now is the
field only transitioning to study cells
in three dimensions and the answers are
fourfold one of which is that there are
new advanced tools to make this easy and
simple and reproducible to do and in
fact shown there is a corning ultra low
attachments lloyd plate which makes it
very straightforward to develop some
farad cell culture technique but
accompanied with this has been
enhancement of the instrumentation you
can do better imaging shown here is
looking at it down a microscope because
there are automated high-throughput
imaging technologies widely available
now and that relates to the other side
of it shown on the third panel there
which is standard high-throughput
instrumentation robotics Bleen have been
applied to the study of 3d cell culture
and that's also accelerating it as a
means by which it can be used in
compound screening and compound drug
discovery and there's increasing
benefits of course in terms of
developing the cells in 3d for the use
in terms of research as well as
therapeutic benefit and the last slide I
do just want to just just talk a little
bit about some of the various techniques
used and the slide here shows the major
techniques
which cells are studied in 3d and one of
the early methods of development was a
hanging drop technique off a cover slip
over a well and in that drop of fluid
the self-assemble into a steroid I've
also talked about the low attachment
plates where most area metrically design
such that the cells will grow into a
steroid you can look at them by inducing
them into a fluid the fluid layer by
introducing magnetic levitation the
cells have a magnetic particle on board
they will come together under the
influence of a magnet but increasingly
there are the techniques coming in the
use of micro fluidics
the use of 3d bioprinting and then also
the influence of growing cells on
Biological hydrogels as well as
synthetic hydrogels as well enabling
tools are propelling this field forward
I've talked a little bit about
microtiter plates shown here is a
steroid microtiter plate it's 1536
which means it can go into an ultra high
throughput screening system and
screening a million compounds a day and
in steroids is now completely feasible
here and you can start to do sort of
sort of imaging here and this is the
imaging of cells as they come together
over a period of time particularly when
one looks at them between 24 and 48
hours and you can start to see that the
cells will form a defined steroid after
48 hours you get one with defined edges
absolutely suitable for high-throughput
imaging techniques just to close the
loop on the micro fluidics there are
organ on chip technologies now entering
the 3d culture area this is one example
of an organ on chip company with various
tissues grown in and in a microchip
environment the advantage here is that
one doesn't just get the microchip
environment one can also have fluid flow
across the cell giving another dimension
by which you're mimicking the in vivo
situation and then finally and there is
the application 3d bioprinting this
one company we've worked with organovo
where one can use various systems to
print tissues here you can print them in
3d just another minute the native
intestinal model and then you can start
to look at K co2 as a model of cellular
absorption just to close then in terms
of applications here one of the major
applications and there's increasing data
published on this is that novel
compounds are being found in drug
discovery is an example of one this
happens to use a 1536 Corning plate and
the group from Scripps here identified
compounds at ulta k res mutations
fundamental mechanism in cancer and they
identified a novel compound that was
active that was not identified using
two-dimensional culturing conditions and
in addition here's another application
where one is developing cells where one
can start to look at glioblastoma
a very aggressive cancer and by looking
at cells grown in 3d you can start to
look at the invasion of glioblastoma
cells in organized developed from the
patient in analogous done in to mimic
I'm in real-time the implication of
cancerous cells in terms of their
invasion of brain tissue and then
finally in the last few slides there is
the area of can you start to have
predictive metabolic toxicology and the
US fda has concluded that liver toxicity
is a major issue particularly in terms
of some of the treatments of compounds
for example with ADHD and in fact if you
look on this slide the number of drugs
that are it's drawn due to toxicity
where they induce liver and heart
failure it's a leading cause for drug
attrition and failure in the clinic and
in fact the slide here shows that if one
studies liver cells in three dimensions
not just can you detect compounds that
have potential effects on the liver but
you're looking at liver cells that are
three times more sensitive to potential
hepatic toxic compounds in other words
the ability to protect the predict
potential liver toxicity is optimized by
looking at liver cells in three
dimensions as illustrated here by some
data using calling cells in Corning
plates
so in conclusion on the promise of 3d
culture is is in three areas one of
which have touched on is more efficient
drug discovery but it also holds promise
for looking at regenerative medicine and
it also has the ability to speak to the
area of personalized medicine so it's
many cells from individual patients can
be grown in 3d and as a result you can
personalize both the disease model as
well as the effect of the compound on
those patient cells my final slide is
really a wrap up slide with some some
comments here a very exciting area a
very fast-moving area an area which is
representing years of culmination of
cell culture research and providing them
with providing us with some various
powerful tools for most drug discovery
and disease research in the future and
with that I'll conclude and I'll hand
things back over to new Susie thank you
and thank you dr. Eglin for that
informative presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2019 as a final
reminder dr. Eglin will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us today we'll see you next time
bye-bye